-Our next guest is
a talented actress
you know from films such as
"Shiva, Baby"
and "Bodies, Bodies, Bodies,"
which is in select theaters
and available on demand now.
Let's take a look.
-I don't know what you're
talking about.
-You hate-listen to her podcast.
-Wait...what?
-And you made us swear on
our lives not to tell anyone.
-Jordan, is that true?
-I like your podcast, Alice.
-What is your podcast about?
-Hanging out with your smartest
and funniest friend.
-[ Groans quietly ]
-Did you just...
groan?
-No.
-When I said "hanging out with
your smartest and funniest
friend?"
Like that! Like that!
-[Bleep]!
-You did it again!
-No, I didn't!
-First of all,
a podcast takes a lot of work,
okay?
You have to organize the guests,
you have to do
a Google calendar,
and -- and you
build a following!
It takes a long [bleep] time,
and I've been working on it
for awhile!
-Please welcome to the show,
Rachel Sennott, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Rachel, I am thrilled
that you're here.
This is very exciting.
I have heard that you wanted to
not just go on any talk show,
you wanted to come on
this talk show
to tell a specific story.
-Oh, yes.
I have a story that I've been
waiting to tell you
for awhile, I want to say maybe
five, six years.
-Okay, so this is maybe,
safe to say, before you're
even in the business?
-This is, yeah.
This is before I'm
in the business.
I had your art department make
a little card for me about it.
Here it is.
-Okay.
So this is you.
"If I ever go on Seth Meyers,
I'm going to tell him
that I gave my first [bleep]
to a guy who was an intern there
and I picked him
because I thought
interning at Seth Meyers
was cool."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-Yes. Yes.
Yeah, I needed to tell you that,
and it feels surreal
and so good.
The thing is, so I grew up,
like, pretty religious.
-Okay.
-Everyone's like, "You, slut?"
[ Laughter ]
But I was really "I'm not gonna
have sex till I'm married.
I'm not gonna give
a [bleep] ever."
-Uh-huh.
-Which isn't a rule
in any religion,
but I was like, "Yeah."
-Oh, yeah.
-"I'm not gonna do it."
BJ, for the folks at home.
-A little late.
-Okay, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Bleep, bleep, bleep.
And so anyways, I was like,
I'm terrified of going to hell.
All my drawings in my journals
are like,
me burning in a fire.
That's how religion works.
And so then so I finally
get to NYU...
[ Single cheer ]
Yeah, school of sluts.
[ Cheering ]
I get there, I'm a virgin.
I'm addicted to God, and, um...
All my friends are like,
"you need to have sex."
I'm like,
"I can't. Not till I'm married."
They're like, "Okay, if you're
not gonna have sex,
you need to at least
give a [bleep]."
I'm like, "At least? That's
the one thing that I can't do!
Ever!"
-Right.
-So I'm trying to pick this guy,
you know,
I need to find the right guy.
This matters.
And we're swiping on Tinder.
This is a period piece.
[ Laughter ]
We're on Tinder and I see
a photo of a young man
standing with you.
[ Cheering ]
And I was like, "Okay, whoever's
getting salads for him,
that's the guy
I'm gonna [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
-Wow.
-And I think I also...
Okay, yes.
This was another one.
-Yeah? Oh, right.
"How does Seth Meyers feel
knowing the pictures he takes
with his interns
will inevitably become one of
their dating profile pics?"
[ Laughter ]
-How do you feel about that?
-Well, look, obviously,
I'm just incredibly honored
and flattered to play even
a very small part...
[ Laughter ]
...in this story.
-Yeah.
I mean, I certainly --
I will say this.
It never even occurred to me
when I throw my arms around,
you know,
the bringers of salad...
[ Laughter ]
...for the photo,
that, you know,
that you're just planting a seed
of a beautiful tree.
-Yeah.
You should advertise that
with the internship.
You're like, "You'll make
a killer breakfast bread.
Something else."
-The great thing is,
the whole time
you've been telling that story,
I keep thinking, like,
"Is there any HR problem here?"
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Do I have any HR exposure?
-And I really don't!
-You don't!
-It's really great.
-If anything in
this situation...
I remember I, like, reached out
to him and I was like,
"I'm looking to
get into comedy.
Can I ask you
a couple questions?"
I'm in trouble.
I reached out to him and then
I got there and I was like,
"So what's Seth like?"
He's like, "He's really cool."
And then we hooked up.
[ Laughter ]
So that -- yeah.
-Thank you for sharing.
It really -- And let me say,
let me really say,
in all sincerity,
thank you for waiting
to tell it here.
If I had seen this story
on Cordon,
I would have been
[bleep] furious.
-No!
That would not happen. I can't.
And then all of the sudden,
I go around,
you see me on every
late night show and I'm like,
I've just [bleep]
everyone's interns.
That would be bad.
No, I have standards.
I only did this one.
-Thank you very much.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's really great.
So in the end, it's a very
wholesome story.
-It's a beautiful story.
Everyone walked away happy.
[ Laughter ]
Everything's great.
-So this is really cool.
First of all, "Bodies,
Bodies, Bodies" is great,
but you're working on a show
with Sam Levinson,
who created "Euphoria."
The Weeknd is in it.
How has that whole process been?
-It's been so amazing,
and I was like,
fans of both of them
before going in.
And again, with the tweets.
I had all these tweets
where I was like,
"The Weeknd is my boyfriend."
And I was like, [bleep]!
Something about working
in this career, I'm like,
I think I've tweeted
something about everyone.
All positive, but
makes me look kind of sad.
[ Laughter ]
-You had to do a little cleanup?
-I had to do a little cleanup.
-A little maintenance?
-A little maintenance
of the timeline.
But yeah, it's been
really amazing.
I'm very excited
for people to see it.
-Also really exciting,
you wrote a film for yourself
called "Bottoms."
Did you enjoy writing it?
And what was the inspiration
for it?
-So I wrote "Bottoms" with my
best friend, Emma Seligman.
She's amazing.
It was really fun
writing with her.
You ride the highs and lows
together.
You're pooping
in the coffee shop.
All of the sudden,
things are good.
Highs and lows, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Which is
"pooping in the coffee shop?"
Is that a high or a low?
-That's a high.
-Yeah, that's a high.
[ Cheers ]
And the lows, everything else.
No, but it was so special.
My friend Ayo Edebiri is in it.
And so it was a really cool
experience to get to
make this movie with our friends
and, yeah.
I'm excited.
I play a nasty little girl.
Yeah, so it'll be fun.
-Well, I'm very, very happy
to have met you.
I do want you
to come back again soon.
-Please.
-And thank you so much
for coming on.
-Thank you for having me.
-You guys,
that's Rachel Sennott!
"Bodies, Bodies, Bodies"
is in select theaters
and available on demand now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."